- Oh my God.
(laughs)
- Girl tell him it was a prank now please.
(bright music)
My name is Jennifer Lauren Arceneaux.
I'm a licensed marriage
and family therapist
and I've been working in the field
of mental health for over 10 years.
I'm really excited to see
what these couples have
in store for me.
So, let's get started.
Let's check out some TikToks.
(bright music)
Oh, Oh honey.
That's so unfortunate when
these artificial milestones
or holidays create real life
relationship expectations.
That's so sweet.
Oh, she's really thoughtful.
Hope she's doing this based
in just her own desire
and not her last stitch
effort to try to win him back.
This is a lot of work. Aw.
I can tell she has some genuine
hope and feelings there.
Long distance is difficult.
I know it created a lot of barriers
during lockdown and quarantine
when you're not even
able to see each other
as much as you typically would.
I hope that she's at a
place now at this point,
a couple of months out.
Either they're back together maybe?
(upbeat music)
Yes day.
Okay. He's aware of what's
going on in her life
outside of their relationship.
Workday stress, pedicures.
That's a good idea.
Oh, oh, she's splurging, at the fast food.
Okay.
Yes with the beauty
and cosmetic purchases.
Hope she ups the undy a little bit.
He's serious.
He's trying to brighten your day girl.
That Yes Day movie, it was cute
but I think it is, you know...
We're saying just to being open
to what our partner wants,
what will make them happy.
That's a nice break from the norm.
This was nice to see.
(upbeat music)
- Achoo.
I'm so sorry.
I'm really sorry.
- Was that your spit?
- I sneezed by accident.
- Oh my God.
Take your spit off me right now. Please.
- I'm sorry.
Okay. You're sorry but
can you take it off?
- I'm not touching that.
- Can you take it off?
- I'm sorry.
- I'm sorry I'm not touching that.
- Please.
What do you mean?
I'm sorry love, I'm not touching that.
That's your problem
now, it was an accident.
- I will get that snot from my throat.
- Go on then.
- I'll spit on you.
- Go ahead.
- Just take this spit off me right now.
Please. I'm asking you kindly.
I understand it was an
accident sweetheart,
but can you please wipe
the spit off of my face?
- Are you getting irritated?
You look like you're getting irritated.
- I have spit on my face.
- And I'm not doing anything
if you're getting irritated with me.
- Tears are about to come out my eyes,
this is disgusting.
- If you're irritated...
- Take it...
- If this was a real incident,
it would have been the proper thing to do
to at least, wipe off this spit.
Yes. We can't just
apologize at word sometimes,
we also need some action steps.
(bright music)
I really enjoyed
all of these TikTok videos.
It's so interesting to see how,
real life things that
come up in my sessions
are playing out in this hilarious way.
It also highlighted how important that is
as a factor in regards to
healthy and happy relationships.
(bright music)